[Music]
yep
i'm a big head for my body no babe it's
pretty proportion
your body is just as big as your head
okay
now that right there you can turn the
camera off now
that's looking monkey tested higher than
me yeah but if you do but in the tv
world if i test as high or if a monkey
and a baby test higher than me
that's a given because monkeys and
babies
kill it because people imagine regular
people
a [ __ ] little monkey oh my god but
you know what babe you are sort of a
cross between a monkey and a baby
that's why you come in third
what the [ __ ] what happened
i [ __ ] fell asleep i think
[Applause]
me talking to the guy was me searching
for the first joke uh no
my name is gilbert i'm not that asian
i'm filipino come on
we are the mexicans of the sea all right
the dog on this side you guys did on the
right
and then this time heading to pigeon so
bringing your left knee up between the
hands
[Music]
all right
flip it babe i want to see what you made
[Music]
yeah because he obviously can't fly
right now his leg is broken
[Music]
walk me through your creation
it's a birdhouse i know but walk me
through there's no there's no
compartments it's just the one bedroom
imagine i'm an architectural digest
i'm not frank lloyd wright it looks like
a flank frank lloyd wright
[Music]
your hands your hands your hands what
the sanitizer right there
i already had some on there oh and in
the inside of your clothes
[Music]
lisa says
stop baby stop doing it because it
destroys my um
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry okay
but you're screaming at the top of your
lungs
it's okay be free
look at all the holes we have in our
shoes
is it already in the oven yeah i already
kind of don't know
oh whoa okay so tell us why you've
chosen the control room
to play video games when we have so many
other rooms
it's privacy and i don't want to bother
anybody i like it in europe
are you sure because we got the vents in
here we have the client if i get sick
whatever i might get it's not sickle
cell you're going to get the irritate
like exhaustion
the gas is exhaustion asbestos
welcome to bob's kitchen today i'm going
to teach you how to make lumoladies
deep dish sausage pizza
you you order it
and then it comes in the nail and then
you preheat the put it over 425
40 minutes five minutes and there you go
a beautiful authentic deep this pizza
from chicago's
anywho when you take it out of the oven
you gotta let it sit for a bit you let
it rest
sit rest sometimes you have to use
different languages how you say
sit there for a sec okay
and then i need it
thanks for watching bob's
show cooking hour
[Applause]
you